do you guys have any irrational fears
because i don't know if i'm like the
only one who has like
how irrational i don't know
i don't know what what is your biggest
fear joey what is your biggest fear my
biggest fear what is your biggest
irrational fear great beard
then we'll actually go sorry decide to
bring up the campaign we'll go back to
the restaurant we'll go back to that oh
yeah that that the beer definitely
helped staying warm i got admitted now
that i've had it grown out yeah yeah my
face was never cold yeah but didn't like
your snot like freeze yeah so so here
because i had a cold it was so cold yeah
uh my snot like like obviously you must
have dribbled while sleeping it like
froze on the like arch of my underneath
my nose and it was awful because i was
like what is this and i flicked it and
then just peeled off all my skin and i
was like wow
ow but yeah the beard otherwise is great
yeah yeah but i think this is the
longest i'll let it go it's getting long
does it get any longer than that it can
do oh really i think it will keep going
longer and longer oh damn but i kind of
want to see you with like the lumps yeah
part of me wants to try it but i'm like
maybe i should just save that for when
i'm bald
well no you got to test it out now
before you go yeah
see if it works all right but i'm not
going to lie i i don't know if there's
there's probably a lot of bearded people
watching this it kind of is getting like
somewhat itchier than than usual yeah
did you get this do you get this bearded
people i don't know no i get it they
probably know solutions that are like
how you maintain a beard perfectly which
i don't know i i sometimes
like one time i grew it out to as long
as it could and it's like i don't think
you'll ever get as long as yours but
like
i remember one time i got i'm at the
baby stages yeah i'm still growing yeah
but like i think that length that you
have is probably the longest it can go
for me oh really yeah because my asian
side forbids it i will say that doing
this feels really nice like just like
yeah yeah have you gone to the point
though where you're like kind of turning
in your bed and your beard brushes up
against the the pillow and it starts to
get a bit issue sometimes yeah well the
worst thing is because we have to wear
masks like yeah
because it's like i'm breathing in like
my own beard like jungle i mean i can
feel it it's ticklish as well yeah it's
like wet yeah yeah it's awful how long
are you gonna grow it i'm probably gonna
shave it tonight not all off i'm just
going to cut it sorry yeah
because i've got a video shoot tomorrow
yeah i'm going to be sad to stop letting
it grow but maybe maybe i'll try it
again you should you should try it you
should try it i'll do it again sometimes
how come you wanted to grow out a bit
longer then i just wanted to see if it
looked better thicker i think it does
look a little better thicker
than normal then i just definitely adds
on the age that's just yeah everybody
everyone i look older i look more angry
it doesn't look older with a beard
though it's true that's what i'm saying
all right i could probably lick my age
if i grew a beard yeah
probably i could see gone in 10 years
with a goatee i don't know why i want to
see that gone with a goatee i could see
it i think i've ever seen you with like
have you ever like grown out your like
beard to like see the where the absolute
limit is before it stops growing or no
because i don't like how i look with a
beard a lot of the times i there's like
this goatee there's like there's like
this perfect sweet spot and then it just
kind of looks like pubes um
like it goes from like nine o'clock
shadow to like wow you uh really should
trim that [ __ ] bush mate yeah yeah
you know and so so i i always like trim
it when it gets to that point um so i i
don't know if i'm ever gonna go out the
bed because yes because cindy's like
yeah it's a good idea it's a good idea
then i reached the pube stage just like
maybe shrimp because
exactly go t gon do it maybe maybe one
day maybe do it maybe when i reach like
my midlife crisis and like you know you
know how like you know you know the
first one there you know i'm like and
when i could do a goatee i could just
shave it all off and be like hello
fellow go-to guys
i did a go team once when i was shaving
and immediately i was like oh god i look
i i i look like i touched children like
it was it was like what the [ __ ] it was
actually
like i immediately i was immediately
like nope i'm not having this on my face
any longer calling out anyone with a
goat
as opposed to like
it just doesn't work for me like i i
realized i have one of those faces that
just like it's either a beard or nothing
like like goatee mustache oh you're not
helping yourself out you like
like beard and stuff like that with like
the really thin beard i don't like that
that doesn't work for me mustache
doesn't work for me goatee doesn't work
for me it's either this or nothing
and i just have one of those faces i
realized you just have to try it out
right i wish mustaches were more in i
like i like i wish i could rock a
mustache must actually look kind of sick
i wish i had the face
just looks like you're about to invent
something yeah
you look like you're about to pioneer
something yeah it depends on what kind
of mustache you have right see like you
could
work a mustache but i don't think i i
don't get like you know that thing that
people have when you don't grow that
much hair in the middle
you need you need it to grow more there
i don't think you would suit him i don't
think so i don't think so no i also
think you'd look like you touched
children
come on you're giving people with a
mustache a bad rap here boys no no no no
no no people some people can rock it so
hard and i'm so jealous of people who
can do that like with the same like if
you had a mustache and those like
[ __ ] massive glasses you know you
know you know what i mean like those
[ __ ] massive glasses you would
definitely the johnson looks like you're
calling out some of our viewers they're
probably gone no but i'm sure they don't
look that bad
just saying it's just my face my face is
just like
like for some people it just works and
there's no explanation for it like i
said here's a still image mood
i've seen
i've seen dudes with like just mustaches
just goatees just boot straps where it's
like [ __ ] you could put someone put some
put some glasses on him as well put some
big gloves put some glasses and then uh
yeah and then you'll see it just doesn't
work for some people i don't know
maybe it works maybe it's just like my
imagination
a 90s porn star
is that a good thing or a bad thing it's
a great thing
you know the two thousand porn stars the
johnny since zero series yeah yeah 90s
is mustaches you know all that that's
like 70s
70s porn stars had like the thick thick
mustache that was a look that was a look
bring it back on
maybe i will tuna imagine you were the
musketeers
[Music]
how much commitment does it take i don't
know how long this has taken this taken
a while
my max i think is like maybe a month and
a half two months
and then and then it hits a point where
it just won't grow any longer ah that's
a long [ __ ] time yeah
it takes a long time to grow up it takes
a long time months
that i don't have
and it looks scruffy in the middle part
you know when it's a full beard and i
can trim it properly yeah maybe it looks
good when i reach my mid-life prices
that's when i'll grow a beard you know
you're saying are you saying i reach for
mid-life sorry have i reached my midlife
crisis i mean maybe you have gone i
wouldn't i haven't got my health check
results yeah exactly that might be
doing something crazy with your facial
hair is like the like the main
equivalent of you know when girls want a
big change in their life and they just
like [ __ ] cut their hair off or
something
[Music]
it's like the male equivalent like i
broke up i cut my hair why is it gone
why we shouldn't
like like you know whenever we need to
change the sigma signal
stigma stigma
if you grow a beard at any point in your
life you're a sigma you deserve it go
you go bro get it get a beard what if
you can't grow a beard though that sucks
to be you wrong
some people just channel sigma but that
doesn't mean you're having a midlife
crisis if you grow a beard gone [ __ ] you
[Music]
you can grow facial hair if you want to
king go ahead
in like my early twenties yeah midlife
course
of [ __ ]
in youtuber years like that's true